the question was from john pierce tell
us about some of your mentors but i
think
a better question is what about you talk
about mindfulness a lot
so my question for you kind of
piggybacked off john's question would be
kind of can you describe your
mindfulness practice and and how did you
get into it was there a spiritual mentor
or someone that
that kind of guided you into mindfulness
well i would start by saying that my
mindfulness practice is
far from perfect and i say that
not only is a reminder to myself that i
can improve tremendously on what i'm
currently doing but also
because i think people think of
mindfulness practices
as some sort of standard that's hard to
live up to
um we quantify it and then say
it has to look like this and if you're
not doing this then you're falling short
and
when people feel like they can't do that
or they
fall off a program then they abandon the
practice altogether
the first thing i would do is define
what does mindfulness practice mean
it can be formal meditation but
mindfulness
is broader than that in the sense that
it's something that we can be doing at
all times
like how can i be more mindful in this
moment so that i can impart
the best piece of advice that i'm
capable of giving
well it means that i have to be present
it means that i have to
ground myself and take a breath
and calm my disposition enough so that
what i'm expressing is done with clarity
and purpose
so we could be in a mindfulness practice
right now
mindfulness does not necessitate formal
meditation per se
but mindfulness is certainly a byproduct
of a formal meditation practice
so my mindfulness practice involves a
combination
of formality and informality
i do have a formal meditation practice
that i do
every morning for 20 minutes i shouldn't
say every morning because it's not every
morning right i'm catching myself in
that
um but the goal is every morning the
goal is every morning and i don't know
and i fall short of that all the time so
the key with that is if you miss a day
not to throw the baby out with the bath
water but just to
start again the next day afternoon
whenever you have it
or if you have five minutes or if you
have two minutes or if you have time
for one inhale and one exhale
that can be a mindfulness practice then
it's about
a constant process of reminding myself
throughout the day
to be more present in whatever it is
that i'm doing
left to my own devices i'm running all
kinds of scenarios like everybody else
i'm busy i'm running all kinds of
scenarios i should have said that why
didn't i call that guy back i got to do
that thing that person let me down
i owe that person a phone call this guy
was supposed to get back to me and he
didn't you know the drill right
so how can i just let go of that
and be present and often that's with
paying attention to my breath and also
just that gentle reminder like oh i'm
doing that thing
let's come back to now let's come back
to now let's come back to now
you think after a while you wouldn't
have to do that anymore
maybe that's true for you not for me
but i will say the more rigorous i am in
my daily formal meditation practice
the easier it is to be mindful
throughout the day
the half-life of that meditation
practice is longer
and conversely the half-life of
my varying emotional states
is shorter so if i get angry i can
get back to baseline more quickly if i'm
frustrated
a quick reminder and i'm back to
baseline and i think that's the real
flex
that you get when you build that muscle
it's not that
you you become some buddha-like
individual
it's that you're more self-aware of when
your emotions are running you
rather than the other way around and you
developed a facility
to resume
a state of equanimity
you asked who the mentors are for this i
mean you know i i've
i've sat with gurus and i've spent time
on meditation apps so there isn't one
person that i can speak to
and i think it's important to not over
complicate these things
if all you're doing is sitting down for
five minutes and you're paying attention
to your breath
and you're inhaling and exhaling that's
really all you need to know
you can go on your own journey to learn
more about all of these
specific techniques and find what
resonates for you
but i'm reticent to like say this is the
mentor or this is the person that you
should follow
the traditions very there's some yeah of
course the tradition's very yeah
depending but do you do you is it a
silent meditation for you
or do you use mantra at all no i don't
yeah i'm not tran i'm not trained in tm
so i don't have a mantra
it's a silent breath practice um and
then i would say
in addition to that training is an
active
meditation for me so if i'm out on the
trail if i'm riding my bike
that's a mindfulness practice and what i
would call an active meditation
but it's important to point out that
that is not a formal
meditation practice and i think there's
a lot of confusion there a lot of people
think
well i don't sit down and load his
position and meditate and i'm not saying
anybody has to sit in lotus position
but going out for a run
even if you're not wearing headphones is
not the same as a formal meditation
practice those
it has value but it's a qualitatively
different
experience and that's something i had to
learn because i used to think
that i didn't need a formal practice
because i go and spend all this time
alone
out in nature that's good enough but i
can tell you
from my own experience that the
difference
in how i feel and how i behave and how i
interact with other people
and the vicissitudes of my emotional
state
are much better when i'm engaged in that
formal meditation practice
the active meditation aspect of it is a
is
a sort of cousin that adds additional
benefit
but not at the expense of
the more formal practice so you just pop
out of the tent on the roof and just
fold right into the lotus position and
go i make some coffee or i make a tea
and then i and then i do it no yoga
first
no no no i try to i try to do the
meditation first first thing before
anything because
also because if i don't do it right then
it becomes less and less likely that
it's going to happen
so it's got to be the first thing okay
yeah and then
i will journal a little bit i do morning
pages
from the artist's way okay and then i
either go out and train
or i use the time for creative pursuits
like this book right now so
i'm actually not training very much at
all because i'm on such a crazy deadline
when do you watch your count videos yeah
is that like
after lunch that's after lunch yes
because i go mine are first thing right
i wake up dive right in
when you're maximally receptive yeah
these ideas
i have research to do so i gotta carve
out like seven to ten hours you have
done your research my friend
[Music]
you